[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[за підтримки «Лавка традицій».
Продукти від маленьких господарств]
[Львів,
Галичина]
Наше кафе знаходиться на такій вулиці,
яка була зовсім невідома.
Але завдяки тому, що тут відкрилося
перше вегетаріанське кафе,
воно стало відоме не тільки на всю Україну —
на весь світ.
У нас є ціла «green family»:
вегетаріанське арт-кафе «Green»,
[Дарія Яремчук
Підприємиця]
виробництво «Зелена корова»
і веганське кафе «Little green».
І в нас є така особливість,
що ми тричі на рік міняємо наше меню.
Крім того, ми проводимо різні концерти,
програми вечірні,
майстер-класи з вегетаріанської кухні.
— О, привіт!
— Добрий день! [сміється]
— Трошки працюєте?
— Трошки працюємо.
— Як настрій?
— Бойовий. [сміється]
Готовий до дій! [сміється]
Для мене було дуже дивним,
що таке велике місто,
і немає вегетаріанських кафе.
[Вадим Хребтов
Підприємець, шеф-кухар]
Я жив у Ялті,
і там вже сезон напрацювали
вегетаріанські кафе.
Жінка в мене зі Львова,
тому для мене Львів
був другим рідним містом.
[сміється]
Чому б, думаю, не поїхати,
не спробувати.
Ми вирішили, що, все ж таки, у Крим
ми завжди зможемо повернутись,
і поїхали.
Вадим — кримський хлопець,
його дружина — Катя.
Вони в поїзді зустрілися дорогою в Крим.
І згодом вони одружилися.
І на тому весіллі був чудовий святковий торт.
Він настільки був смачний!
Я перше: «Хто зробив цей торт?»
[сміється]
Вадим так скромно:
«Та то я вночі вже
накидав усіх інгредієнтів, які в мене були».
[сміється]
«І от щось таке вийшло».
Ну він був настільки смачний,
я зрозуміла, що це — талант.
Ну ми дуже багато працювали над нашими стравами.
Ми хотіли щось таке цікаве
і показати людям
багатогранність вегетаріанського харчування.
Тому що в основному люди думають,
що вегетаріанство — це овочі.
Подивилися, що в Азії дуже, дуже багато продуктів,
пов'язаних із соєю.
На початку було складно знайти
постачальників якісних продуктів,
які не містять ГМО,
або не мають в складі глютену, якихось [ще] речей,
що на це є певні підтвердження.
Зрозуміли, що так само виробництв тофу
не так багато і є,
а тим більше отакого традиційного
азійського продукту тофу
взагалі не існує в Україні.
У нас трошки інші технології
виробництва чомусь.
Один мій друг каже:
«А ти не хочеш зробити виробництво?»
[Ременів,
Галичина]
Мені, до речі, вчора дзвонив
той наш, Ярослав Григорович.
Каже, що десь поблизу
розпродавали, мовляв, завод.
Питає мене: «Ти нічого не купив?»
Я кажу: «Та я навіть не знав».
Ми взяли за основу
азійську традиційну технологію,
так, як виговляють там.
І головне обладнання — саме оце.
Її називають «соєва корова».
Це те, що безпосередньо ми «доїмо» з сої молоко.
Ось це — головний наш апарат.
Є соя замочена, яка поступає
в апарат на млини:
так само, як борошно, тільки в мокрому вигляді.
І все це перетирається з додаванням
певної кількості води.
Після цього воно фільтрується,
сепарується, відділяється конкретно молоко.
Далі молоко проходить термічну обробку, вариться.
І після цього це вже є молоко,
яке безпосередньо можна вживати в їжу, пити.
Воно — так зване цільне соєве молоко.
Тофу, як і будь-який інший сир,
робиться процесом коагуляції.
Утворюється згусток, так само, як звичайний сир,
зрушується, складається по формах,
відпресовується і відправляється вже охолоджуватися в ванну
до подальших процесів.
Соя — це наш основний продукт,
основна сировина для кожного продукту,
майже всюди вона присутня.
Соя — наша, українська,
вирощують її у нас тут.
Ми їдемо безпосередньо до тієї людини,
до фермера або до аграрія,
який займається вирощуванням.
Беремо тестову кількість на аналізи,
перевіряємо її, по-перше, на присутність ГМО.
Так само — на залишки пестицидів
і на мікотоксини.
Коли я почав займатися вегетаріанством,
я просто подивився на Азію.
І що зараз кажу всім іншим людям:
якщо в неї було щось таке,
що не можна було використовувати
для вживання в їжу конкретно для людини,
чому тоді всі країни Азії,
вони просто з дитинства, так?
Як ми тут п'ємо коров'яче, вони там п'ють соєве.
Там є всі незамінні амінокислоти,
які потрібні для людини.
Я прийшла до вегетаріанства через хворобу.
За якийсь час я зрозуміла,
що я не хочу повертатися до м'яса, до риби.
Зрозуміла, що я хочу по-іншому жити.
Мені хочеться допомагати людям,
давати їм знання, яке я маю,
яке мені допомогло, у першу чергу.
У нас досить-таки немалий асортимент.
Ми робимо тофу, фалафелі,
хумус,
паштет соєвий
і один продукт, це є «Керобелла».
Це солодка страва,
але вона теж дуже проста.
Там арахіс, кероб
[плоди ріжкового дерева] і фініки.
Фалафель — це традиційна східна кухня,
котлетки з нуту.
Процес ручний, все ретельно змішується,
накручуються кульки
і обсмажуються.
Це є нут безпосередньо — турецький горошок.
Так само ми використовуємо жом із сої — окару,
те, що ми туди додаємо,
суміш спецій і рис.
Зараз ми будемо готувати
одну з найпопулярніших страв у нашому кафе —
це хумус із фалафелем.
Ми зробили її незвичайною,
ми зробили з подачею трьох різних хумусів.
Хумус так само робиться з нуту, як і фалафель.
Це взагалі «нут в нуті», яктдеякі люди кажуть.
Ми підбираємо, щоб страва смакувала кожному,
щоб для кожного вона була смачна,
чи то сироїдна страва,
щоб вона була смачна і для людини,
яка вживає тільки сире,
і для людини, яка взагалі не дотримується
навіть вегетаріанства.
Ну прийде, буде смачно.
Одна з цілей була — показати,
що можна харчуватися здорово
повністю, так,
і це смачно, це поживно, це корисно.
Порівняно з першим роком,
наше виробництво виросло в десять разів.
Є такий інтерес в людей до здорового харчування,
до здорового способу життя.
І міняється свідомість людей.
А це, власне, була наша ціль з самого початку.
Ми хотіли людям дати це.
І зараз [це] на часі,
ми зараз на часі.
Моя справа — це моє натхнення,
це моя творчість,
це моя любов,
це моя турбота про інших.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисерка
Марія Теребус]
[Режисерка монтажу
Надія Мельниченко]
[Оператори
Олег Сологуб, Назар Назарук]
[Звукорежисерка
Анастастасія Климова]
[Асистентка продюсерки
Наталя Вишинська]
[Субтитрувальниця
Леся Любченко]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]